new study is refuting claims made by
researchers Eric Lerner and rendra Gupta
who say that there's too many Bright
Young galaxies than possible if the Big
Bang happened but these claims are based
on images seen by the James web Space
Telescope however new research has
completely obliterated these claims
putting the Big Bang Theory on a more
solid footing than ever newly discovered
galaxies brilliant beacons of Starlight
shine with an intensity that shouldn't
be possible their Luminosity defies
their understanding of how stars are
born and how galaxies evolve just a few
hundred million years after the big bang
but something didn't add up some people
even claim the Big Bang never happened
new simulations published in the
astrophysical journal revealed these
galaxies might not be as luminous as
those researchers once thought instead
their Brilliance is a byproduct of
intense short-lived burst of star
formation fueled by Cosmic gas clouds
creating stars at a furious Pace but the
star party is shortlived sputtering out
just as the fuel Runs Out plunging the
Galaxy back into relative Darkness this
discovery is a GameChanger so the next
time you hear the Big Bang never
happened remember that